joining me now is pastor lorraine jones
whose son dwayne simpson was tragically
stabbed to death in brixton age just 20
as he did the honorable thing and tried
to save someone else's life dr victor
elisa a former chief superintendent with
the met police and we'll be hearing from
bobby kasanga who spent eight years in
prison for armed robbery and i'm told
has turned his life around and he now
runs a football club in hackney london
and works to keep young people away from
crime welcome everybody i just want to
start lorraine with you
every day
we hear of yet more tragedy
as a mother who lost her son how did you
feel
when you heard about that nine year old
girl last
night i'm still choked up
it's like we're experiencing a horror
which we dreaded
eight years ago
and the
violence has
escalated
out of london across the country and
nine-year-old girl
innocent
shot in the chest
if this isn't a wake-up call
for everybody to come together to deal
with this i don't know what it's going
to take i'm with you and and you know
what i find really frustrating is that
we talk about it bobby welcome to the
show um
i wanted to do this a little bit
differently and i hope you understand
why i know you've turned your life
around but i
people watching this tonight are going
apart from the fact that we can't afford
to survive a lot of us right now how the
hell are we supposed to walk outside the
front door
for fear of what happened to that kid
explain to me
how you ended up being jailed for eight
years for armed robbie how did you get
into that situation bobby um peer
pressure lack of of opportunities
no positive role models inequalities
and ultimately beyond all of that is
choice and greed because we can talk
about all these things i've talked about
the lack of equality um lack of
opportunities but there's so many people
came from the same environment as me who
didn't choose the lifestyle i did so i
like your honesty did you carry a gun or
a knife what did you carry um
obviously we've had guns in that before
as well but it wasn't anything that
actually ever used it was just in
participation of the robberies at the
time and it comes down to deprivation as
well thinking that you need something
that you actually don't you see all
these things
everyone else has and you believe you
need them but we didn't have the was
naive we didn't have the knowledge to
know that you have to be patient so
that's why when we work with our young
people now it's all about teaching them
patience and just allowing and waiting
for your time because
everyone
that was doing these things with me i've
got over 20 people who i can say i've
been killed that i knew personally i've
got never over 20 who are doing
life in prison so although i've come out
of that system i've lost many friends
along the way because of that same
system when you looked at that news last
night of that nine year old what was the
first thing that went through your head
absolutely shocking because even in any
form of criminality they take part in
everyone knows the kind of saying is
that women and kids it's a no-go area so
for someone to go and do that it's
absolutely disgusting when you look at
her look look there in the eyes her son
was stabbed to death you carried a knife
what do you say to her i mean i've met
um the lady many many times and we've
spoken a few times and it's the thing
that where
i know now when i was younger i was 14
15 16 it's a lot of that help me out you
talk you're very honest because a lot of
people go inequality or opportunity tell
me if i'm wrong
so many of the kids who end up in gans
gravitate towards that that unit because
the family life isn't great are we right
to blame parents in many instances or
not no because my parents were both hard
working that they were strict with me
it all comes down to again choices and
the fear of missing out parents told me
be home at 8 00 pm
your friends are hanging out so the
first thing you start doing be
disobedient to your parents by going to
hang on a bit later on because you
you're fearing the missing out of the
fun that everyone's having what did they
say when you went to prison for eight
years oh they were disappointed they
were absolutely disappointed gutted
because i was in the top set at school
it wasn't like i was someone that didn't
know what i was doing i willingly took
part in the activities that i did
because i was greedy and i wanted to
compete and um keep up the joneses
everyone knows how nice things i want to
be with them my parents couldn't really
afford it but it's my choice um victor a
former met police superintendent um
i speak to the police the whole time
peter blexi will be an example and he
says that police men and women
don't have the time anymore to deal with
petty crime because they're social
workers they're mental health operatives
that stat
that crimes under a thousand pounds is
something like just not being
investigated we have heard every plan
and this great desire to reduce the
levels of knife crime gun crime just the
lawlessness that we're talking about
what needs to happen what is the
solution in your mind well i mean you'll
have politicians say that we can't
police our way out of problems but i
think the police can play a really
significant part um you know taking what
we're talking about at the moment the
examples you've given those people
involved whether it's the offender with
the gun where the nine-year-old girl was
tragically shot whether it's the 58 year
old pensioner who was stabbed those
people are carrying weapons in public
places now how do we incentivize prepare
our police so they can do their work in
public places no stabbing takes place in
private you know and then just having
off oxford street in the premises
you don't expect the police to be in
there but give the police the
opportunity the time to do the work on
the streets it's one of the things that
actually the police are too busy no
disrespect to any of them i think
they're great but they're too busy
filling out forms and ticking boxes on
computers rather walking the beat and
finding out intel and doing the job that
they used to go have we moved policing
away from that common touch and that's
why we're missing out that's the first
question well that is the first question
there is bureaucracy but again you know
i guess we can't put that away because
police officers work independently and
when we want to hold them to account the
only way we can do that is through the
records that they've made and we can't
move away from that but what we can do
is reduce that bureaucracy we can
actually give the police the time to be
able to do some of the work we want them
to do on the street and more importantly
you talk about the other issues you
describe them as social work issues well
there are other public agencies who
should be doing that you know when i was
a cop i've resided for you know five
years prior to that my officers would go
and deal with someone who had a mental
health problem they would spend two or
three hours
now they're spending six seven hours
because the other public agencies are
not being compelled to contribute to the
work that needs doing you can't blame
the police for that because the police
can't walk away if they get called they
have to go and deal with it lorraine one
of the things that i think really
strongly about you might agree or
disagree is i don't believe
that the the the punishments are strong
enough i look at what happened with acid
they gave life imprisonment to acid and
it is with absolutely a known fact that
those crimes are gonna do we need to be
stronger on people who carry knives and
guns most definitely
my son's killer got 12 years he'd done
half of that he's out enjoying his life
my son's gone for good and we've been
affected for life
the sentencing
needs to be revised
and modernized
there's no way you can give a higher
sentence for a robbery than for taking
someone's life my son's killer he was
sentenced for
manslaughter because of how the
criminal justice system label
years and
how it how it came about that he's
killed my son it's outrageous so that
area definitely needs looking at it's
not acceptable because
more and more are carrying knives and
guns and they're younger
younger the youngest child i was called
by a parent to report an incident at
school was seven years old he brought a
scissors from home a sharp one and
stabbed the other boy in the leg
seven years old
bobby
i agree with lorraine about the criminal
justice system i'm sorry if people don't
like it i think that the sentencing
should be much stronger and and and i
really do believe that as a kid who
perpetrated towards the gang and was out
on the street
did you think hey you could get away
with it did you not consider the
implications and do you today the man
that has turned his life around and runs
this football club in hackney and gets
kids to understand that they need to
change their lives do you think if the
punishments were greater that would help
the situation i think there needs to be
a balance
i think you can't write someone
completely off um
there's some people like myself who
where prison works and there's
rehabilitation i went to prison and
decided to get degree
while i was in there there's others who
won't learn who come in call back out
again so there needs to be a kind of a
balance maybe someone gets given a very
harsh sentence
and then you monitor them throughout the
sentence are they doing the right
courses are they doing the right things
are they getting a degree but but you'd
understand uh you know her son's killer
got 12 years and he's out after
does that say 100 100 i i get that but i
guess um he was sentenced to
manslaughter so the court judged him to
have um committed manslaughter compared
to murder he was out
and then he was recalled back after six
years so like what you're saying there
needs to be some restorative justice we
can't just put him in prison and leave
him there they're learning all sorts in
there and they're coming out raving mad
i don't know if this man that has shot
and killed this
child has reoffended there needs to be
restorative justice do you agree with
that quickly victor and i've got to
finish
yeah absolutely there needs to be a
balance but um we need to be very clear
for those people that you know bobby's
talking about those people who will not
respond to the imprisonment then we need
to throw the book at them but we need to
be clear there are some people that are
just so bad prison is the only thing for
them we also need there are people like
bobby who respond you know to a positive
input in prison and come out a very
different person guys fantastic bobby
thank you victor thank you and lorraine
jones thank you very much indeed um now
yesterday i told you that tyson fury
will be joining us on the show today
following the tragic death of his cousin
rico burton who was stabbed to death in
manchester at the weekend tyson got in
touch with the show this morning to say
the situation is so raw he and his
family utterly devastated by the loss
and he didn't feel able to come on
tonight we obviously send tyson and the
family are deep with sympathies and hope
very much to have him back on uncensored
soon when he is ready that's an open
open office